se dice que nuestra forma de mirar crea
la realidad que vemos
así como echemos nuestra mirada al mundo
así como el mundo va a aparecer
hoy quería invitaros durante un rato a
que nos pongamos todos unas gafas
especiales durante un ratito que yo
llamo gafas holísticas gafas holísticas
y vamos a ver que captamos de una visión
del ser humano y de las organizaciones
pero vamos a echar una visión no una
visión cualquiera sino una visión
holística
una visión completa abarcan te recuerdo
cuando yo era pequeño a mí me decía que
el ser humano estaba compuesto de cabeza
tronco y extremidades y yo con eso me
servía hasta que más adelante descubrí
que no hay otros niveles verdad hay un
nivel de la vida que es lo que nos
mantiene vivos los procesos no la
digestión
el metabolismo el sueño y a esto le
podemos llamar el cuerpo vital del ser
humano el primero en el cuerpo físico
eso de la cabeza el tronco y las
extremidades y esto puede llamarlo el
cuerpo vital del cuerpo vital que nos
mantiene vivos naturalmente tenemos
otros niveles un nivel más arriba
estaría nuestro mundo de las emociones y
a este mundo lo podemos llamar el cuerpo
emocional o cuerpo astral si queréis que
se llama a veces porque antiguamente se
creía que en cada astro vivía una
emoción el amor en venus la ira en marte
ya sé
pero si nos movemos un nivel más arriba
al cuarto nivel
encontramos la parte más fundamental de
un ser humano es lo que nos hace humanos
precisamente me gusta llamarlo el yo
otros lo llaman la individualidad la
parte espiritual la conciencia pero en
esta parte del yo es donde se ha
producido la capacidad de hablar la
capacidad de pensar
la capacidad de ser creativos
de amar
de aspirar a la libertad
y es en ese nivel del yo donde residen
nuestros valores nuestros valores que
son el origen de nuestros actos de
nuestro comportamiento y por último lo
más importante de todo en ese nivel del
yo está la misión nuestra misión para
que hemos nacido que tenemos que hacer
aquí
para que estamos en este planeta
bien pues esta visión holística del ser
humano
qué serían estos cuatro niveles si ahora
consideramos lo que es una organización
o una empresa
podemos pensar que es un organismo
social porque es un organismo por estar
vivo social porque está compuesto de
seres humanos que están trabajando e
interactuando por tanto podríamos llegar
a tener la hipótesis de que la
organización también tiene esos cuatro
niveles un cuerpo físico un cuerpo vital
el cuerpo emocional y el yo ahora bien
que hay en cada uno de esos niveles en
una organización
si miramos al nivel primero al cuerpo
físico evidentemente es todo aquello
material todo aquello que vamos a
observar lo que podemos tocar las
maquinarias los edificios los
ordenadores muy importante también que
en el cuerpo físico no lo consideramos a
menudo está todo lo que se puede medir
todo lo que se puede contar por ejemplo
una organización estaría el número de
clientes estaría los resultados
financieros de la empresa estaría el
índice de absentismo laboral por ejemplo
y por último en el cuerpo físico hay que
tener
hay que reflexionar que es donde
aparecen los síntomas si algo va mal en
la organización si tenemos una
enfermedad en la empresa donde aparece
el síntoma finalmente es en el cuerpo
físico y lo vamos incluso a poder medir
si nos elevamos al segundo nivel el
nivel del cuerpo vital
al igual que el ser humano en los
procesos en la empresa también son los
procesos puede ser la contabilidad
pueden ser la logística el proceso de
formación de las personas o el proceso
de venta
y son los procesos que realmente
mantienen a la organización funcionando
el cuerpo astral que sería el tercer
nivel sería ese cuerpo de las emociones
que son realmente el cuerpo de las
relaciones es donde aparece el trabajo
en equipo aparece la motivación donde
nos peleamos donde salen los conflictos
donde hacemos las negociaciones es un
nivel realmente convulso no es nada
quieto es un nivel que generalmente
produce mucho dolor en las
organizaciones este nivel del cuerpo
astral
y por último ese cuarto nivel el más
importante es el nivel del yo de la
identidad en las organizaciones
efectivamente es donde está la identidad
de la empresa donde aparece también un
logotipo que sería la representación
gráfica de esa identidad
es donde están los valores hoy se habla
mucho de valores pero no se reflexiona
que de los valores es de donde emergen
nuestros actos nuestro comportamiento
podemos decir que nuestros valores son
así pero si nuestros actos
de la tan otra cosa nuestros datos nos
van a delatar y ya se dice que por sus
actos los conoceréis por tanto es
fundamental reflexionar los valores y
alinearlos con nuestra estrategia
y por último quizás lo más importante
del yo es la misión la misión podrá otro
factor que hoy se habla cada vez se
habla más pero no se habla con la
suficiente conciencia para que existe
esta empresa para que hemos fundado esta
iniciativa de qué va cuál es nuestro
papel en el mundo
bien esto está visión holística que
hemos echado sobre el ser humano en las
organizaciones nos permite
realmente observar cómo actuamos cada
vez que tenemos un problema cada vez que
tenemos un desequilibrio o una
enfermedad en este organismo social en
esta empresa en esta organización
normalmente lo que hacemos es lo
siguiente y es que si tenemos un
problema en el cuerpo físico que son las
instalaciones e igual que un individuo
acudiría a un dentista o un cirujano o
masajista en una organización
normalmente llamamos a un electricista a
un pintor un carpintero es lo que
podemos llamar chapa y pintura en plan
sencillo es lo más simple lo más
evidente si tenemos un problema en el
cuerpo vital
en el ser humano donde acudimos vamos
nuevamente un especialista vamos a un
especialista digestivo o de una
especialista endocrino o de lo que sea
en el caso de una organización acudimos
también un especialista o un
especialista de procesos
puede ser un especialista informático un
especialista en logística o un
especialista en información
qué hacemos acude a la empresa nos
arregla el problema que tengamos pagamos
sus servicios y decimos adiós hasta la
próxima porque habrá una próxima vez lo
sabemos
si tenemos el problema del cuerpo astral
que en el caso de una persona iríamos a
un psicólogo en el caso de una
organización a quien acudimos acudimos
nuevamente a un consultor o un coach que
trabaja con personas
viene a la organización nos ayuda no
resuelve el problema
le pagamos y nos despedimos hasta la
próxima porque es que habrá una próxima
vez y naturalmente el problema aquí es
que precisamente la intervención que
hacemos siempre está centrada en el
problema
siempre que tenemos un problema hacemos
una intervención centrada en el problema
y es como si nos entregaran un folio en
blanco por un puntito negro en el centro
y nos pidieran que lo describamos y nos
empezamos a describir el punto
que está más a la derecha más en el
centro que es más grande más pequeño más
oscuro y nos olvidamos del folio
totalmente nos centramos siempre en el
puntito podéis hacer la experiencia
por eso es fundamental que añadamos un
trabajo sobre ello sobre ese nivel tan
importante y tan tampoco consciente
sobre el yo de la organización es en el
yo de la organización donde tomamos
conciencia de quiénes somos de nuestros
valores y de nuestra misión
y es ahí en ese nivel donde encontramos
el sentido de nuestro trabajo
cuando hacemos un trabajo sobre este
nivel lo que estamos es generando un
torrente de salud en la organización es
un torrente que inunda a la organización
es como si fuera
una nubecita que pasa empieza a llover y
empieza a filtrar el agua y evita que se
produzcan fuegos
y bueno este escenario que se nos abre
con esta visión holística
nos permite realmente sacar buenas
conclusiones para nuestro trabajo
cotidiano en las organizaciones que
además es donde pasamos gran parte de
nuestras vidas
y es fundamentalmente que cuando
encontramos el sentido de nuestro
trabajo
se dispara enormemente la motivación
la motivación y la creatividad de todo
el mundo que está trabajando
y esto es fundamental para la vitalidad
de esa empresa
y además es que redundan los resultados
sean los resultados sin acciones de la
empresa van en aumento y de manera
sostenida
antiguamente en la antigua grecia en el
templo de delfos ponía hombre conócete a
ti mismo
y ha sido realmente este impulso así el
impulso de todo ser humano durante la
historia de la humanidad a conocernos a
nosotros mismos
pues bien hoy creo que tenemos que
ayudar a nuestras empresas a conocerse a
sí mismas
y para ello los responsables de la
organización
tenéis que hacer uso de vuestro talento
más estratégico que es el coraje
es el coraje para ponernos manos a la
obra
y descubrir nuestra verdadera identidad
los valores de la misión y para hacer
partícipes a todos los que trabajan con
nosotros
para que se entusiasmen al encontrar el
sentido del trabajo
y de esta forma lo que vamos a lograr es
una sociedad más sana y más creativa
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí